light heavyweight right now that belt
can get passed around I think it's me so
tough to defend that belt you need a few
Champions which is insane which is great
it's entertaining but you're not getting
another Jon Jones run but I think for
people to write Jamal Hill off is kind
of crazy he's only getting better he's
only been doing it for three years in
the UFC think how much of a leap he made
in this Glover fight see how much better
he's gonna be in the next fight against
the ankle live yeah he's gonna be an
underdog because they ain't Club wants
to wrestle his ass off yawns he's gonna
be an underdog racket Underdog Yuri
Underdog Anthony Smith probably pretty
close even lines there it's tough to say
I think he's gonna lose his next fight I
don't know this kid's pretty
good dude